[Applause]
the moment
the curtain opened and it was time to
perform
our turntable started spinning in
Reverse backward
freaking all of us out
on live television
and there was nothing we could do to
stop it Harry Styles's backup dancer is
dishing on his Grammy performance
revealing one major technical mishap
yard
on Sunday Harry took the stage to
perform his hit track as it was on a
spinning stage similar to the one in his
music video
[Music]
and while the whole thing looked
Flawless to us one of his dancers is
opening up on social media explaining
they rehearsed with the stage turning
one way but when the curtain went up it
was spinning the opposite direction
throwing them all off so after a week of
rehearsing this piece perfectly going
this way the moment it's time to perform
it starts going it's going late and in
real time we have to troubleshoot and
try to do a complete piece in Reverse
some eagle-eyed fans even noticed Harry
signaling to the technician that the
turntable was going the wrong way
[Applause]
[Music]
but despite all that Harry and his
dancers managed to pull off a great
performance and US Folks at home we had
no idea
and when ET saw Harry backstage he
didn't seem phased
technical glitches aside our turntable
started spinning in Reverse backward
freaking all of us out and there was
nothing we could do to stop it it was a
great night for Harry like a really
really great night he had a friendly
reunion
's Taylor Swift he rocked not one not
two but three show-stopping looks and
took home trophies for best pop vocal
album and the coveted album of the Year
this album from start to finish has been
the greatest experience of my life so
let's hear it for Harry and his dance
answers for pivoting literally like
bosses and proving that the show really
must go on
[Applause]